most people will likely remember why it
started and the people who knocked these
buildings down
will hear all of us soon
a demand to the taliban turnover osama
bin laden and al qaeda unanswered a few
weeks later
a massive bombing campaign along with a
small force of around 1 000 special
forces soldiers and cia agents combined
with the northern alliance in
afghanistan
and the taliban fell within months the
u.s along with its allies turned to
nation building with big promises of
lessons learned
we know this
from not only intelligence but from the
history of military conflict in
afghanistan
it's been one of initial success
followed by long years of floundering
and ultimate failure
we're not going to repeat that mistake
critics say that's exactly what happened
as the u.s turned more attention to the
war in iraq the u.s announced an end to
major combat operations in afghanistan
in 2003
a constitution was written elections
followed a new president a new
legislature with women taking positions
of power but as the years passed cracks
in the coalition
[Applause]
and as the taliban fought back and
civilian casualties mounted along with
that of the armed forces
opinion turned a new u.s president had
to make a decision go bigger or go home
our overarching goal remains the same
u.s president barack obama decided to
send an additional 17 000 troops then 30
000 more by 2010 around 100 000 u.s
troops would be in afghanistan in may of
2011 osama bin laden was found and
killed in pakistan but the war continued
obama promised to bring most u.s troops
home by the end of 2016 and then a new
u.s president took over
a hasty withdrawal
would create a vacuum that terrorists
including isis and al qaeda
would instantly fill
president trump announced an open-ended
deployment but eventually signed a deal
with the taliban if they promised to
keep out terrorist groups and not attack
u.s troops a full withdrawal would
happen by may of 2021
but then yet another new u.s president
was sworn in and president joe biden
decided to keep the deal and leave only
a small troop presence he said the
taliban would not immediately take over
he was wrong
sending in more than 5 000 troops to
hastily evacuate the embassy
now growing questions of what will
happen to the women and girls of
afghanistan 20 years of bloodshed and
battles
of promises and of unimaginable pain of
encouraging signs and setbacks
two decades of war and still questions
of what was won
amid so much that was lost patty calhane
al jazeera washington